Okay, today I'm gonna teach you how elections work in Canada. Why?
Because nobody knows how elections work
and I'm tired of Twitter and TikTok
trying to understand what's going on.
So we're gonna teach them.
Are you guys ready? Yeah,
that's the spirit. I'm gonna draw Canada.
You ready for my Canada? I'm thinking
Ding, ding, ding.
Oh, oh,
hey, the cookie.
What about the islands? Ding, ding, ding.
That looks like Ontario, not Canada.
There's some islands up here that looks like New Zealand.
Got Pei. You get the point.
That's a pretty picture right there.
What are the political parties in Canada?
Yeah, go executive.
The federal political party. The name of the parties?
Black Panther. Black.
All right, in Canada we have three major parties.
We have the NDP, New Democratic Party,
we have the liberals,
and we have the conservatives.
I knew that. You knew that,
but you said Black Panther anyway.
All right, there's also two other parties,
the Black Hibachois and the Green Party,
but they're not major parties in Canada.
You with me so far? Listen,
before we have an election in Canada, right,
each political party has its own convention,
meaning they have their own little party.
And each political party then has people within that party
fighting for leadership of that party.
So if we were all one party,
you guys would all fight who's gonna be leader
and whoever wins gets to be leader of the NDP,
the liberals, the conservatives, Okay,
so here's what happens next.
Are you ready? Canada as a country is divided up into 338 sections,
338 ridings, let's say each riding,
so each area, so if I divided it like this, right,
let's say those are all the areas of right?
Each area has approximately 150,000 to 200,000 people in it.
So in Canada, it's all broken up into 338 ridings, right?
Each one represents a certain the same number of people
and then each riding has its own election.
The NDP and the Liberal Conservatives
all put people in each riding in hopes that they win many ridings,
right? It's like you can't win if you don't play kind of thing.
So they put people in all the ridings across Canada,
all right, once each political party puts candidates in each riding,
there's an election all across Canada and everybody goes to vote,
but you only vote in your riding.
So if you live here,
you're just gonna have the choice between the candidates
that they have chosen to run in that riding.
Now, after all 338 ridings have run, okay,
the elections happen, everybody,
whoever wins each riding, they get a trip to the house of Commons.
I'll draw the house of Commons.
House of Commons,
come on, that's impressive.
Let's run the house of Commons. Okay,
the NDP have a total, the liberals have a total,
the conservatives have a total of people that they elect,
whichever political party gets the most seats
Let's say it's the liberals
that's who sitting there
their leader who they chose at the beginning of this whole thing
their leader becomes prime minister.
We don't actually choose the prime minister,
we choose the party and the person in our riding.
Whoever they chose is their their leader.
That's the individual that gets to become prime minister.
Also understand this
our prime minister gets to stay there for five years.
There's no limit on how many times they can be reelected,
but they can always call an early election.
So when the majority of people in the house vote for an election,
they say we want election now if if over 51% vote for election,
we have to have a new election and start the whole thing over again.
What's your question?
Does the public know who the leader of each party is?
Yeah, so the public know
so even though you're not directly electing the leader,
you know that if you vote for a conservative in your riding,
you're technically gonna be voting in some way for Pierre Poliov
and his leadership. If you vote Liberal,
you're voting for the leader of that party who is right now Trudeau
and if you vote NDP, you're voting for Jugmeet Singh,
but you're not voting directly
because unless Jugmeet or Pierre or Trudeau is in your riding,
you don't get to vote for them directly.
Any questions? How are you going to vote?
I can't tell you how I'm Gonna vote.
It's secret. That's up to you to decide. Stop pressuring me.